so you have yourself a nice little
weekend what I want you to do is order
yourself a large pepperoni pizza from
Domino's get extra sauce so you know
it's fresh even though if you don't like
the sauce if you just ask for a regular
pizza it's going to be old one they get
off the shelves you order it with extra
sauce it comes hot piping into your door
you do that on Friday at 800 p.m.
Eastern you watch the one Championship
Muay Thai World Championship Muay Thai
it's going to be fun Ukrainian 67
knocking dudes out all right then you
got the 16-year-old doing the damn thing
he's 17 now but you know what I mean you
eat that pizza you watch one champ ship
on Amazon Prime at 8:00 p.m. Eastern